- In Hungary,
we were able to
unify these forces
through the lands of nation.
If you love your country,
it doesn't matter whether
you are classical, liberal,
libertarian or
religious conservative,
then this is the point
where you have to be united
and you have to be able
to use your resources
against your political opponents
because they are using
everything what they have.
The institutions, the state,
transnational organizations,
media, academia.
And until that moment
we, on this side,
were just too silent
and too fragmented.
(upbeat music)
- I'm Dave Rubin.
This is "The Ruben Report"
from the local studio
right here in Miami.
And joining me today is
the political director
for the Prime Minister
of Hungary, Polish Orban.
Welcome to "The Ruben Report".
- Hi. Thank you very
much for inviting me.
- I am glad to have you here.
A freedom fighter
from across the way
here in America in the
free state of Florida.
I was trying to think how I
wanted to do this interview
because I will be
very honest up top.
I don't think
Americans know much,
if anything, about Hungary,
and I am not gonna pretend
to be a Hungary expert,
so I thought the best
way we could start this
was a little Hungary 101.
If I say to you, tell
me about Hungary,
what does that mean to you?
- I think all the people of
United States and Florida
would love Hungary because
it's a small but old
central European country with
a thousand years old history.
As you were referred,
we are known in Europe
as freedom fighters
because our history is about
constant fight for sovereignty.
We were several times
occupied by foreigners
like the Ottomans, like the
Habsburgs or the Austrians,
like the Nazi Germans
and the Russians.
And we survived.
And right now we
are proud members
of the European Union and
the Western community,
but we have our own values
and we are very proud
of our nationhood,
our country, our traditions.
And that's the reason, I think,
why we came part of the
international debate,
at least inside the
western civilization,
about the future of
this civilization.
Which direction should we go
and if there is a dead
end street or not.
- So interestingly, the
guy that connected us
was my good friend
Peter Boghossian,
who has been on this
show many, many times,
who you've met a few times now.
And he's in Hungary right now.
And was for most of his life,
a lefty atheist, but
in search of freedom,
in search of places
where order exists
and western values exist.
And he lives in Portland
where he's struggling
to find it there.
- Yeah.
- Goes to Budapest
and he's finding it in Hungary.
- Yeah.
- That's interesting.
- He is a great guy.
Currently, we,
at least those who are working
for the Hungarian government
and Prime Minister Orban,
we are conservatives.
We are Christian Democrats,
We are obviously representing
the political rights side.
Out of question.
But according to our
understanding, it means freedom.
Freedom of speech.
Freedom of thinking.
Freedom of expression.
And we have to preserve,
protect pluralism
in our society.
If Peter is there and he
speaks openly about his views,
we can argue.
We can debate with him.
Actually, we are
organizing debates
to show that these
are the alternatives.
Let the people choose.
And what he keeps telling to us
that it was the case
in United States.
It was the case in some other
western European countries.
But currently, this is
not the case anymore.
Leftist ideology wants
to control everything.
They want 100% power,
not separation of power.
We, small central
European conservatives,
we tried to manage a
political refugee program
for people like
Peter Boghossian.
- And, interestingly, most
of my audience will get it.
You then are called all of
the worst things, right?
- Yeah, sure.
- You're a fascist.
You're a bigot. All right.
I should mention that, although
your last name is Orban,
you are not related to the
Prime Minister Victor Orban.
- No, no.
- Correct?
That must get very messy.
- No, and it's not the case
that you have to change
your name to Orban
if you want to go to
politics in Hungary.
- (laughs) Yeah.
Okay, you talked about
the values of Hungary.
What do you think those
values are, ever since,
from the way you described it,
but what broadly do you
think those values are?
- I just came from
the conference of
national conservatism.
- Yeah.
- I think this is
an intellectual movement,
which is very close
to our thinking.
And the basic pillar of this
movement is the idea of nation.
We all know that we are in
the era of globalization
and time will not change,
so we have to adapt
to that situation.
But I think the challenges
of the previous decades
like the pandemic, like
the economic crisis,
like the migration crisis,
what we are also
facing in Hungary.
They prove that the
nation, as a concept
is the only form which
can serve the interest
of the citizens and
of the community
who are living under the
rule of that destination.
Everybody is talking about
globalized cooperation
on international organizations.
And if there is sunshine,
and if there is trade
between the nations,
I can imagine that it can do
good things for the people.
But if there is trouble,
if there is wind
and bad weather,
you can only go
back to your nation,
to your own government.
They should be
responsible for you
and for the people who are
part of that community.
This is the basic idea.
Unfortunately, it's not
very trendy or mainstream.
- (laughs) We're working
on it. We're working on it.
- Working on it.
And it's not easy to talk
about God and religion
because that's a
personal matter.
But still, we do
think that these God
and the idea of
religion, and tradition,
and the teaching which comes
from the Bible through,
for example, Christian
democratic political philosophy,
it has to play a
very important role
in building a well
functioning society,
even in the 21st century.
- I spoke at a couple panels
and gave a talk at
NatCon last year,
and that was one of the
main things that came up.
How do you blend
as wokeness infects
all of the Western
institutions and governments?
If the return is to be
something of a return
with some level of
religiosity in it,
what do you do about the
people outside of that,
either the non-believers,
or the gay people,
or just anyone that is not
within the Christian tradition
as you would see it?
And I know this is
a big debate going.
- No, no, it's a huge debate,
but according to
our understanding,
probably it's different
here in the United States
or even in Poland,
a country which is very
close to us in Europe.
We are not focusing on the
individual belief of the people
because it's a
freedom of decision.
If you want to be onboard,
if you want to take it,
if you want to be a believer,
if you want to be an active
church goer, you can do so.
You are not allowed to
be punished for that.
But if you don't want to
do it, then it's fine.
- Mm-hmm.
- But the ideas,
the political ideas,
which are coming from
this kind of of concept,
they are useful.
Family is a basic
pillar of society.
- Mm-hmm.
- Family is based on the idea
of a marriage between
a man and woman.
And one of the most important
goal of this kind of marriage
is to raise children.
And those children will
be the next generation.
Without those children, there
is no community anymore.
It's not about the
individual decision,
whether you are homosexual
or heterosexual,
whether you are you want to have
one children, or two, or three,
it's about that from
a society perspective,
the more the state can do
for those who are ready
to go into a marriage
between a man and a woman,
and ready to take as many
children as they want,
then the state's role
is to support them
through state institutions.
This is the idea.
- One of the things
that you've been doing
is encouraging
people to have kids
because you wrote
a piece recently.
You're worried about
population collapse.
If you listen to
mainstream media,
it's basically that the earth
is gonna be overrun with humans.
We're gonna have
no resources left
and there's too many of us.
And if everyone
could have less kids,
that would be good.
And you see it in
a different way.
- Yeah, I think it's just
the other way around.
And especially, we Hungarians,
we are a small nation,
just 10 million people.
Probably, for big empires,
the historical perspective
is a bit different.
But for us, we think that we
have a very unique culture.
We have a unique language.
We are an island in Europe.
We want to preserve it,
and we need people
and we need children
who are ready to be
the representatives
of this culture in the future.
If we don't have these people,
then everything what is
linked to Hungarianness
will disappear, and we
don't want to let it happen.
We need people.
- It sounds like you're
fighting in many ways
the same wokeness, the
same top down thing,
that it's a little hard to
tell where it's coming from,
but corporations, and
globalists, and all this stuff.
When did it start in Hungary
or where did it start?
How powerful is it?
Is it like America,
where now it's in
all of our TV shows,
it's on the news all the time,
our corporations are part of it.
Is it a similar feeling there?
- Wokeism and gender ideology,
it's a brand new
issue in Hungary.
And it came through the
transatlantic channel,
so obviously it came,
unfortunately, from
the United States.
But the Hungarians, we were
occupied by the Russians
like 40 years.
And through this period of
occupation, the Russians,
they did try to teach us
to Marxist ideologies.
Constantly in school,
in universities,
everybody was repeating
the nonsense Marxist ideas.
In an average Hungarian or
aggressive Hungarian voter,
they are the resistant
against this Marxist...
They were resistant
again, actually,
against the Marxist propaganda.
And when the woke came in,
they immediately realized
that there is a connection
between the original
Marxist ideology
and the woke, or the
gender, ideology.
It's a new Marxist.
- How was it coming in though?
Was it coming in through
television that was imported,
or movies, or was there
something more coordinated?
- Yeah, culture and NGOs.
Media and NGOs, they are
playing a very important role.
First was whether
the soccer players
should go down to
the knee or not.
- You had your own
version of that
relative to the Hungarian flag?
- No, actually, we were,
through international media,
forced to follow this thing.
And we were saying, look,
I know it's
controversial issue here
in the United States as well.
- [Dave] Mm-hmm.
- But I understand that some
of the people are saying
that it's about racial
equality, which is important.
And about the black communities.
But we didn't have any
slavery in Hungary.
We don't have any
black community.
This is a cultural reference
point which is not ours.
It's not a problem if
somebody else is doing that,
but if we are forced to do
so and forced to follow,
then it's something scary.
And then a couple months later,
the educational issues came in.
And NGOs and media people,
they started to launch
campaigns in schools.
How to make it easier for
children to change their sex
and they questioned
their identity.
The whole LGBTQ-
- [Dave] Yep.
- Movement came in.
And then we realized
that this is serious.
We accepted legislation quite
similar to the Florida one,
to protect the minors and ban
sexual orientation classes
without the consent
of the parent.
And we were immediately attacked
by the headquarter
of the European Union
by the bureaucrats.
And then we made
the decision that
our only chance is...
This is common sense,
what we are saying,
and it will be
backed by the people.
We launched a referendum.
And in this April,
we had a referendum on this
gender ideological issues.
Four questions.
And the Hungarians said, with
an overwhelming majority,
92% of the votes.
- Wow.
- And the turnout
was was the biggest
in the history of referendum
of modern Hungary,
so more people participated
in the referendum
than in a migration issue,
than in a NATO
enlargement issue,
or EU enlargement issue.
And they voted with
a huge majority
against these gender
ideological things.
And it's a huge success.
- And where does your
media fit in that?
Was the media doing
what our media does,
which is here in Florida,
calling Ron DeSantis
a homophone?
- Yeah, sure.
- Making up all that.
Do you see it as a very similar.
- It's the very similar pattern,
but the only difference is
not only the domestic media,
but the international
media is on us as well,
and it makes very
hard to survive.
But we have no other chance.
Once we are supported
by the people,
so we don't have to be popular
in the editorial board
of the New York Times.
We have to be popular
among the Hungarian voters.
We have to represent
their ideas.
And second,
if the western in
civilization goes forward
to that direction,
that's gonna be a
suicide mission,
so somehow we should
turn back or turn away
from this direction.
And to do so, you have to
stand up and be outspoken,
even if it's controversial.
- You mentioned right
before we started.
We spoke only for just
two or three minutes
before we started.
You said something about how
the other European nations,
that there's very few
people in the nations
willing to stand up
for their own nations.
And that seems to be the
fight that you guys have.
Who else is doing it right?
Is there anyone else?
Poland seems to maybe have a
version of this that's working.
- Yeah, that's true.
Poland is a strong country,
four times bigger than Hungary.
It plays a very important role.
They have a clear
conservative government.
They have a very tough
nation state tuition
and they are doing
great economically.
Very successful.
Actually, there are everywhere,
political forces who are
representing the same ideas.
The only problem is
that the establishment
is doing everything
what is necessary
to not let them let them in.
- [Dave] Mm-hmm.
- There will be election in
Italy, end of this month,
and the Italian right
side is doing great.
The coalition of
right wing parties,
they are leading in impose,
so it can be a game changer.
- In this piece that I
read that you laid out,
we talked about the
population portion of it
and why you want people
to have kids and multiply.
- The topic migration
is linked to that.
- That was the next
one I was gonna-
- Yeah, sorry.
Because it it's linked to the
idea of population decline.
If we can agree on
that, we need people,
then some of the laborers
are saying, okay,
from labor market point
of view, I agree with you.
- [Dave] Just open up.
- Just open up.
But then you lose everything,
what makes you what you are,
because those people
who are coming,
they obviously coming from
different civilization.
They are bringing in different
civilization of backgrounds.
- What's been the general
immigration policy of Hungary
over the last decade or two?
What's the general...
If you wanna come
in with the migrants
and the presence you guys
were under, your opinion?
- Yeah.
The general approach
is very simple.
We have experience neighboring
countries, ethnic Hungarians,
or those people who
are belonging to
neighboring nations,
they are trying to
come to Hungary.
Legally, we make it possible.
Illegally, we don't
support that idea.
And currently,
we are hosting more than 1
million Ukrainian refugees.
They are our neighbors.
We have the humanitarian
responsibility for help them.
But what we experienced in 2015,
that was the first time
that something is happening.
And it's totally different than
what we experienced before.
400,000 illegal migrants
came to our southern borders
and they wanted to just come in
and cross the border
without any permission.
And they just wanted
to go to Germany.
Some of them wanted to stay,
but many of them wanted
to go to Germany,
Sweden, and other countries.
And this was the point when
Prime Minister Orban realized
that the migration, what
we were talking about,
it's completely different
from what we will experience
in these debates.
And if we look around
South Africa, North Africa,
Middle East, Central Asia,
there are millions of
millions of people,
10 millions and 10
millions of people
coming from
overpopulated countries
and they want to start
a new life somewhere.
And Europe, that's
the closest continent.
They want to start
without any permission.
They want to start a
new life in Europe.
- What was that like in 2015?
Everyone remembers the videos
of just watching people pour.
We see these videos now from
Mexico into the United States.
- Pretty much the same.
- In essence, it seemingly
kind of happened overnight.
It was obviously related to the
war in Syria and everything.
Did you stop people immediately?
- Yeah.
- How quickly?
- The tricky thing was
that the left was saying
that it's mainly linked
to the war in Syria.
- Yeah.
- It's a local conflict issue,
but we hosted people on
our Southern borders.
They were coming from
more than 100 countries.
Not just Syria.
Back at the time,
it was just 30, 40%.
It's a more broader issue.
We immediately realized
that if our country
is not able to
protect the borders
and to restore law and
order then we are lost.
We established the fence.
We build the border fence.
It was a three months
operation and around 150 miles.
And we stopped them.
And we introduced the
border control measures
where we stop everybody who is
not have the right to enter.
- Were you getting
threatened by the EU.
- Of course, of course.
Since then, that's a
constant legal cold war.
- Right. What do they try to do?
They try to force you
to just let anyone in?
What are their
punishments really?
- There were several punishment.
The latest is that
they are attacking us
through the courts.
They are in charge of the court
system and the institutions,
and they try to block
all our legal mechanisms
to stop the people.
Because the idea is that if
you are an illegal immigrant,
you are not allowed to enter
the country and walk freely.
You have to apply for asylum.
And until the decision is made,
you are not allowed to enter
the territory of the country
because then you're
gonna disappear
and it'll be
impossible to find you.
And this is the basic idea,
which according to
their understanding,
goes against the humanitarian
law requirements.
But it's nonsense.
Those humanitarian
legal requirements,
those are outdated.
Those are historical memories
based on the Geneva
Convention from 1951.
Back at that time, the
thing was very different.
- Do you think they
don't even know
what they're calling for
or do you think it is
more nefarious than that?
When you when you
see this coming in
either through the
ideas of wokeness
or quite literally the people
walking across the borders?
- Well, no, I think it's a
political program of the left,
and political program
of George Soros
and his Open Society Foundation,
because they think
that European nations,
they are threats of the future.
What they want to do is to
deconstruct these nations.
How can you
deconstruct a nation?
You have to change
the population.
You have to let people in
who are coming from
different civilization
and give them citizenship
as soon as it is possible.
They are not Christians.
They are mainly Muslims.
They don't share our values.
They have their
own value system.
They are very proud of it.
I don't want to judge
this kind of value system.
Probably it works
in Muslim societies
or definitely works
in Muslim societies.
But in our society, what the
value system is, is different.
And those people, if they
come in and they settle,
they establish parallel
societies immediately
and they are supporting leftist
liberal political forces
with a huge majority.
For them, it's a
political program
to destroy the old European
type of nation states.
- When you talk to
your counterparts,
either in Germany
or in the UK places
that let tons of people in
that have these
parallel societies,
do they go, Man, we're jealous.
You guys are a little
ahead of us on this thing.
We missed it.
- According to
our understanding,
this is a mistake.
What you can have only once.
And if you make that mistake,
and you let millions
of people in,
and you give them citizenship,
then it's over because
you have no other chance.
You have to live
with those people.
And what our
counterparts are saying,
look, you are right, but
our situation is different.
I have to at least try
to convince those voters.
I cannot be the defender of
the Christian civilization
if 20% or 15% of my voters
are coming from
different background.
Most probably, you were right.
Most probably, we
made a bad decision
because we were only looking
to the economy
consequences of decision,
not the cultural
consequences, but that's it.
That's why we are
here. We have to be.
And Prime Minister
Orban is, in the sense,
the most tough anti migration
politician in in Europe
because we have to be
very tough on that issue.
Once you commit this mistake,
these people are in,
they are part of society,
and the whole
equilibrium is changing.
- You mentioned
the Prime Minister
and I know that he
either was or is friendly
with our former Prime
Minister, Donald Trump.
And obviously a lot of the
things you're talking about
in terms of borders, and
culture, and things like that
sound sort of Trumpian.
Was that a nice little
time for you guys
when there was similar
leadership in the United States
that I suspect is a little
bit different right now?
- Yeah, that's true.
Honestly, in domestic
politics, we are the strongest.
We won four consecutive term
with 2/3 majority
people are on our side.
- What does that mean
in terms of the vote?
What percentage of the
vote roughly is that?
- More than 50%. More than 50%.
Which our system, it
differs from your system.
It's not the two party system.
In the European
context, that's huge.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- But internationally, inside
the Western hemisphere,
the situation is not so good.
For example, in 2016 when
President Trump came into power,
Benjamin Netanyahu was
Prime Minister in Israel,
Brexiters were
emerging in in London.
We had Anglo American,
that was a Christian
democrat coalition based,
but still Christian
Democrat government.
- Although, she did let
a lot of migrants in,
which probably-
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
But right now in
the Ukrainian issue,
we would need European
leadership of the Germans
and we don't have this
kind of leadership.
We had huge conflicts with her,
but she's missing right now.
Not because of
the migrant issue.
Because of the
geopolitical issues.
Back at that time,
international
corporation was easier,
but I think better
days should come.
The polls are on board.
Italy, there will be a
changing of the government.
I hope in the United States,
during the midterm election,
the Republicans
will do a good job.
And the economic
situation in Europe,
it's very hard.
Energy prices are skyrocketing
and middle class is suffering.
Serious problems.
And all the countries
are governed by left
wing governments,
so I think we will have a
very turbulent political time.
Is it crazy to you or obvious
that so many of the nations
are going through this
at the exact same time?
Almost everything you're laying
out here, to some degree,
is pretty much
what's happening here
and it's pretty much
what's happening in the UK
and all over the place.
But I guess that's the point.
- We are connected.
Yeah, we are connected.
I think, for the liberals,
it's very easy intellectually
to incorporate on an
international level.
Because if you are a liberal,
it means that you
have your principles,
your value system,
and it's universal.
It doesn't matter where you are.
It doesn't matter
whether you are in DC,
in Scandinavia, in
Africa, in Southeast Asia.
If you are liberal,
then you have your values
and you want to turn the
government into that direction.
And you have no conflict with
the others who are liberals
but living on the other
side of the world.
But for the conservatives,
or in a positive
way, nationalists,
it's hard because
all your beliefs
are coming from the
history of your nation.
It's historically,
sociologically, geographically,
it's based and it defers
from the views of others.
And that's the reason why
cooperation is very hard,
because we will never
agree 100% on everything.
Because you are following
the interest of your nation
and I am following the
interest of my nation.
But through mutual
respect and understanding,
I think this kind
of cooperation,
if you are able to
make these connections,
then in the long term,
they can be stronger
because it's rational and
based on mutual respect,
which is always a
good starting point.
- But it's a tough
experiment, right?
- Very, very.
- This is what they're trying
to figure out at NatCon.
Can you take ex-libs
and libertarians,
mix 'em with these
religious conservatives,
all fight wokeism,
and it seems to me
that everyone right now
is kind of willing to put their
swords down to make it work.
But the question is,
okay, if we make it work,
what happens after that?
- Yeah. Oh, I don't
have the answer.
The only thing I know is-
- I hope we get to see
'cause then we'll have
at least defeated woke.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, sure.
In Hungary, we were able
to unify these forces
through the lands of nation.
If you love your country,
it doesn't matter whether
you are classical or liberal,
libertarian or
religious conservative,
then this is the point
where you have to be united
and you have to be able
to use your resources
against your political opponents
because they are using
everything what they have.
The institutions, the state,
transnational organizations,
media, academia.
And until that moment,
we on this side were just too
silent and too fragmented.
- We talked about a little
bit related to migration.
Ukraine, now how many
refugees did you say?
- 1 Million.
- 1 million that are to be
settled to become citizens
or they're in some sort of-
- No, no, no, no.
- 'Cause that's
10% Of population.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, that's huge.
They left Ukraine and
they came to Hungary.
We managed an operation to
host them and help them.
Some of them went back,
some of them went to
other European countries,
but some of them stay.
- What is Hungary's position
on what's going on there?
I'll say that to the backdrop
of I haven't covered
Ukraine much on my show
because I've found it's
extremely difficult
getting an honest assessment
of what's going on
and who really are the
good guys and the bad guys,
and everything else.
It's just been very messy.
- Yeah. According to
our understanding-
- And I also live in a country
that's halfway across the
world, not right there.
- Yeah, yeah, sure.
It's not your problem.
- But it is.
But it is because all of
these things are integrated.
- Because of the prices
and so on. Yeah, it's true.
I think it's out to question
that the Russians are the
aggressors in that story.
- [Dave] Of course, of course.
- And the Ukrainians are brave
and they are protecting
their country.
And we should help them,
but it's a question of peace
and prolongation of war.
What we are doing right now,
the westerners, together...
That's the NATO
strategy, let's call it.
That way that we support
through military equipments,
weapons and so on,
the Ukrainians,
and they are fighting
and they are doing good.
But the war is still there
and it's gonna stay
there for a long time.
And the consequences of the war,
they are destroying
our economies
mainly through the
energy sanctions.
- Can you describe how that
directly affects you guys?
The US or NATO put
sanctions on Russia.
- In the field of energy,
and it brings up the
prices immediately
because some countries
are not allowed
to buy Russian gas or oil.
It means that it's
like a trade market,
so immediately the prices are
getting higher and higher.
And you have to buy
the energy from somehow
because Europe is
not independent.
If the energy prizes are high,
then it immediately
causing inflation,
and it is causing
serious trouble
for manufacturing companies.
If they close, then people
are losing their jobs.
It's a process.
It's a rational economical
process which is going on.
According to our understanding,
this war should be stopped,
but not stopped
through escalation
or prolongation of the war,
but through peace talks.
Our position is that the west
and obviously the United States
should be involved with them
because the Russians,
they take only seriously
the United States.
There should be
Russian US peace talks.
We would need
immediate ceasefire
and try to cool
down the process.
- Is there even any
talk of that right now?
- No, unfortunately not.
- What do you make of that?
- Fortunately not because I
think the American position
is that this kind of
prolongation of war,
it weakens Russia for sure.
The Ukrainians are
willing to do so,
and the Europeans
are not strong enough
to represent their own
interest in that situation.
I'm mainly talking about
France and Germany.
- That there's no real
credible threat behind them
if they were to come to
the table with Russia.
- They are politically
also fragile,
so coalition government,
the different parties,
they have a different
opinion on that.
The international
mainstream is very hard
on putting pressure on
those who are saying,
look, it shouldn't be a war
propaganda around this issue.
But we should do the
other way around.
The peace propaganda
should be started
and spread everywhere.
But we are not close to that.
But unfortunately, the
winter will be very hard
and I hope that sooner or
later everybody will realize
that the prolongation of war,
it's just not a good way to end.
- What do you think the off
ramp looks like for Russia?
What's something that they
could sit down and say,
okay, we got this, we
can end this thing now?
- I can have my own opinion.
Hungarian leadership can
have its own opinion,
but we are not a game
changer in this situation.
It should be done
by the big players.
We are just a small
mouse in the room.
There are big
elephants in the room,
they should make
their own decisions.
But the problem is
that currently nobody,
as you mentioned,
nobody's talking about
these kind of peace talks.
Everybody's talking about
that we should keep going.
We should go further.
What is happening there.
And the Ukrainians,
they made just recently
a good counter strike,
but then the Russians
made a counters strike.
The whole story, from a
humanitarian point of view,
it's getting even worse
and worse and worse.
And we should stop that.
- Yeah.
I wasn't even planning on
mentioning this to you,
but I guess what's sort
of sits with all of this
is we have a major
censorship problem
here in the United States
and a completely, I would say,
media that is in complete
dereliction of their duties,
and deeply dishonest,
and not friendly to
a lot of the ideas
that we're discussing here.
I'm curious on two things.
How is your media generally?
What about censorship,
and what's going on
with the internet,
and big tech and
all of those things,
how much of that is an
important part of your world?
- No, it's a very
important part.
And from our perspective, media,
it's a sovereignty issue again.
So if media is
owned by foreigners,
then foreigners are dictating
what the Hungarians
should think.
The first and foremost
important point
is that at least the majority
of the Hungarian media
should be owned by Hungarians.
It doesn't matter whether
they are liberals,
conservative socialists,
what ideology they have,
but it should be in
a hand of Hungarians.
In that sense,
we are in a much better shape
than we were 12 years ago
when the Orban government
came into power.
The other thing is that
pluralism is important.
The variety of opinions
should be visible,
and Hungarian people should
make their own decision,
which opinions they
they want to follow.
And in this sense,
I think the Hungarian
media is a better shape
than the media in
western in Europe
because the balance
between so-called...
It's obviously
oversimplifying the things,
but the liberal views and
the conservative views...
The progressive liberal views
and the conservative views
is it's quite balance.
So it's 50, 50.
- Interesting.
And do you find you
have counterparts
on the progressive liberal side
that you can debate publicly
or get into these
conversations with?
Because that's what's going on
here, that's very difficult.
They don't seem to
wanna debate anymore,
or even have these
conversations.
- Yeah, that's a good question.
Sometimes they are on
board with the debate
and they are available.
But then they make a decision
if they're interested is that,
and they close down everything
and they are not communicating.
- Well, because to be clear,
whoever might be
the counterpart...
I know you don't
have a counterpart on
the progressive side
because they're not in
the government right now,
but I would have that person on
and treat them the
exact same way.
But I suspect after
talking to someone
with a last name Orban, that's
probably not gonna happen.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But, I think it's important.
And we conservatives, or
the Hungarian right side,
we are confident
because we think
that the truth is on our side,
so I am confident that I
can win all the debates.
I'm always ready to
discuss these things.
But their mindset
is a bit different.
You mentioned the
big tech companies.
They are playing an even
more and more important role
in Hungarian public sphere.
And the censorship is obviously
an issue there as well.
Our situation is even
worse than your situation
because those tech companies,
their headquarter is
in the United States
or in another European country,
so we don't have
those companies.
What was done by, for
example, Governor DeSantis
that through taxation
and through some
legislative actions,
he wanted to create
a fair treatment
for all the political opinions.
We Hungarians and the other
small center European countries,
I'm not saying we
are, we are toolless,
but we don't have as much tools
as you have here in
the United States.
That's why for us it's important
that the Republicans are
pushing this thing forward
because otherwise it
will have an effect
on the other European
countries as well.
- What level of censorship
do you guys think
you're dealing with?
It's almost impossible to tell
because once you're
being censored,
and throttled, and all of
those things, you don't know.
But I would imagine
if the Prime Minister
was to put out something
that they could even
frame as anti-immigrant...
And I've read a
lot of his speeches
where they go completely insane,
call him racist and
all of these things.
And if you read it,
it's actually quite measured
and sort of what
you've laid out here.
Can you even tell what
level of censorship
you're dealing with?
- It's not as bad as it
happened in the United States
that the one platform
banned the president.
- And then everyone banned him.
- Yeah, and then everyone
banned the president.
It did not happen yet.
But I experienced
as well as a politician
and some other politicians
also experienced that.
And we know that those people
who are in charge of making
these kind of decisions,
they are not accountable.
But we know them,
and from an ideological
perspective,
their opinion is
obviously not balanced.
And making these
kind of decisions
shouldn't be made by
private companies.
It's so simple and it's
not a brand new issue.
It wasn't invented, this
thought, just recently.
It's well known for centuries
and thousands and
thousands of years,
that these kind of
decisions should be made
by independent branches.
That's why we invented the
idea of independent judiciary.
And currently, the role of
the independent judiciary
is done by these private company
censorship group of people.
I think it's nonsense,
but I'm quite optimistic
because through the history
of the technological
development,
when the all the new
platforms were coming in,
first radio, and then
the television, and
then the internet,
and then right now
the social media.
There was always,
at the beginning,
a kind of a turbulent time,
when the state
made the takeover,
so it does not mean that there
should be state censorship,
but through legislative power,
at least some fair balance
should be immediately
established.
And they did with the
radio, with the television,
with all the platforms.
Just took couple years.
- Right.
- I hope it's gonna happen too.
- But when you say you
hope it's gonna happen,
do you mean from
an American side,
because these are American
companies, for the most part,
that you want something to
happen on the legislative side?
- Yeah, yeah.
- I hate to tell you, my
friend, I don't think so.
- Or at least in Europe
because probably we Hungarians,
we are just small
players in that issue,
but Europe as such
is 27 countries.
This is something which
should be discussed
on the European level and
we should act together.
But until that moment
it did not happen.
- I normally don't end
on a question like this,
but is there anything else
that you wanna hit on?
I think we hit most
of the big stuff.
You're here in town in Miami
for the National
Conservatism Conference,
as we talked about,
and that that's ongoing
for a couple days.
And they're trying to
hash out all the things
that we've discussed.
Did you hear anything
else interesting there
that is on your mind
or relevant to Hungary?
Or have you been
shocked by anything
since you've been here
in the United States?
It worse than you
thought? Is it better?
- No, no, no, because all the
Americans I know and I like,
they are anti woke and
they are very nice people.
And they are very
nice to my country.
- Yeah, yeah, you
should go to Portland,
see what's happening.
- Yeah the situation
is different for sure.
But I have to say that
always I come to here,
I become more optimistic.
I know that you are
also serious trouble.
But if I keep
talking with people,
the idea of American greatness,
it emerges immediately.
And I think at
the end of the day
you will figure out something.
The only thing I keep
telling them that,
I know that America is special.
I know that it's
like an elephant
and all the others are just
smaller animals around you,
even the Europeans.
But there are some small
animals, some mouses,
and sometimes the smaller
animals, the mouses,
also can help the
elephants to survive.
These kind of alliance can be
beneficial for most parties.
- That was a beautiful ending,
however I did say to you
right before we started,
I said, this is a
beautiful cover of a book.
The book is "The Hungarian
Way Of Strategy".
Can you just tell the
people what this elk
on the front of the book is?
- It's an elk or stag,
and the idea, according
to Hungarian history,
the Hungarian tribes,
seven tribes who
occupied the land
where we are living more
than 1,100 years ago.
They were led by this
special creature.
She was the one who
was doing the lead.
And through this animal,
a transcendent power or
God was leading the way.
The idea of the cover
is that this stag is
still here, still with us,
so the future is not
so pessimistic for us.
- Now that counts as an ending.
- Thank you very much.
- My pleasure.
Appreciate.
- If you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful
conversations
about international issues
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our
international playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
check out our full
episode playlist.
They're all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.